comme une tornade la guerre a tout
balayé sur son passage
près de kiev habits chief bombardée
pendant des semaines les maisons sont
aujourd'hui réduites à de la tôle
froissée et des amas de poutres le
bâtiment de l'école a tenu les habitants
reviennent récupère les quelques jouets
quelques cadres épargné
difficile pour cette professeure de
reconnaître sa salle de classe
donc j'avance c'est tellement dur quand
ce sont des enfants qui souffrent
après près d'un mois sur la ligne de
front ces routes en périphérie de kiev
sont désertes les troupes russes ont
reculé mais laisse derrière elle des
villages dévastés où résonnent encore au
loin le bruit des tirs
cet homme revient une semaine après
avoir fuit encore marqué
pendant trois semaines nous avons été
bombardés nous avons vu des gens tués
nous avons vu des maisons brûlées
on a vécu l'enfer on a vécu l'enfer
sur certaines routes désormais des
carcasses de chars
et dans les champs au sud du pays des
mines que ses équipes tente de
désactiver profitant du recul des
troupes russes un peu plus loin dans ce
village occupé pendant plusieurs jours
le drapeau ukrainien flotte à nouveau
ses habitants qui n'ont pas quitté la
ville sont fiers d'avoir résisté aux
soldats russes
nous avons tiré sur ces fascistes autant
que nous le pouvions
il méritait
les habitants doivent maintenant
reconstruire retrouvez l'avis sur les
ruines de leur village